chi'lan change
which what'd you catch very cool shimmy
the governor creamer over to messianic
Dena a given device
the corporates are Republican moving the
media now quachita Minnesota era then I
was suggesting a contagious Asian but
you can say and not quite she lavishes
[Music]
you can mr. Mannion one
Yokogawa preserve public are no madam
byaku ha ha he was recruited you which
are true when you're gone because the
winner wonder shoot to do wonder crazy
Rehan again we're vanishingly what Chris
said literally walking ok you say oh no
no not at all you know see the solitude
- English army I should see my broom
handle us a PC because aquifer Tonya not
cream traditional Ultima because the
chief attorney we do terashima to rob
you Regina
Travis tema candy Travis's Iranian true
Khun na na na na - enugu CCD kanya
candy-coated el Camas I quit arena in
Kigali ok you can he
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
which is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one that refers she can watch the seeker
[Music]
which is a mature query
today to amateur Creed II need to know
cream to the Johno cream - Chandra
degeneracy the economy sorry Samir
kodkod case a quick occur before
agriculture hm PMS accrue
which are selfish a welcome to come here
in Kenya behaviors Morocco's a
nourishing me thank you so much
I've been requested to do some bitter
explanation and the comments I just made
I want to say we are happy we are
grateful to all the Buddha who is there
is translation
so I'm hoping that everyone understood
that I said thank you so much thank you
Patricia thank you thank you we will try
to communicate a little bit later thank
you I should say new appraisal república
new marriage a multicolored moving a
million a Quadra preserve okay dr. mundo
is my appear a cottages on two nitrogen
air crew now cuz a cool man and wife
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
economic earth
to us question I watch a lucid passage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
decryption
[Music]
if I charge the battery info quick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you miserable Sammi Tommo can you
Basava